let's look at divisibility by the
numbers three six and nine first we look
at divisibility by three a number is
divisible by three if the sum of its
digits is divisible by three is twenty
five thousand seven hundred twenty two
divisible by three this number has five
digits let's add them two plus five plus
seven plus two plus two 2 plus 5 is 7 7
plus 7 is 14 and 14 plus four is 18 so
the sum of its digits is 18 is this sum
divisible by three yes 18 is divisible
by three hence this number is also
divisible by three if the sum is not
divisible by three then the number two
is not divisible by three let's zoom out
and understand another divisibility rule
divisibility by 6 is not the simplest
but it's definitely very interesting
there are just two simple conditions we
can say that a number is divisible by 6
if the number is even and is divisible
by 3 both these conditions have to be
satisfied it has to be even and it has
to be divisible by 3 since the test is a
bit different we will look at two
examples the first one is four hundred
and seventy nine thousand six hundred
twenty-three is this number even since
the last digit is not divisible by two
this number is not divisible by two
hence this number is not even so we
don't need to check for the other
condition here even if one of them is
not satisfied the number will not be
divisible by six here it's not even and
hence will not be divisible by six
consider one hundred and ninety thousand
one hundred sixteen this number is
divisible by two as the last digit
divisible by two hence it's even the
first condition is satisfied now we
check for the second condition we check
if it is divisible by three a number is
divisible by three if this sum of its
digits is divisible by three so we find
out the sum of the digits one plus nine
plus zero plus one plus one plus six
one plus 9 is 10 plus 2 is 12 plus 6
gives us 18 the sum equals 18 so it is
also divisible by three
hence this number is divisible by six
now we come to the final divisibility
test of this video the test for
divisibility by nine is similar to that
of the test for divisibility by three a
number is divisible by nine if the sum
of its digits is divisible by nine is
two million four hundred and seventy
nine thousand four hundred and one
divisible by nine the sum of the digits
equals 27 since 27 is divisible by nine
this number will also be divisible by
nine
you